I think though that it that that is
changing I mean in a number of
universities that I'm familiar with
people are thinking about how they're
going to make appointments in in Indian
philosophy or Islamic philosophy and so
on and I think there's actually a quite
rapidly increasing awareness that that
these other traditions do contain many
thinkers who can in principle be be
studied in the same kind of way that for
example Plato and Aristotle are already
studied in Western philosophy
departments but I think one thing is
that the analytic tradition is is not a
very historical tradition it's it's one
which because it has a broadly
scientific conception of philosophy
thinks that there's quite an important
distinction between philosophy and the
history of philosophy just as you know
you wouldn't expect that in a physics
department people are spending most of
their time on the history of physics and
and in fact it's the case that lots of
areas of the Western tradition are also
neglected for example medieval Western
philosophy is very little taught in
Western universities but and I think
it's also the if it's going to be taught
it has to be taught in in a way that
makes it come alive as philosophy and I
mean the danger with some of these texts
is that they're that they've they've not
been well translated and so that it's
they just seem very obscure and and you
can't it's difficult for people who are
reading them in translation to engage
with them philosophically but you know I
do think that that is where a teething
problem and there's there's no reason in
principle why it can't be overcome but I
mean at the moment in Western countries
are actually not many people who are
capable of doing the teaching that's
required so you can't expect a fast
expansion but there is an expansion
and I would expect that to be you know a
growing trend over a future but isn't
that import duty pressure from the
students rather than the pressure coming
from from academics themselves it's the
students who are encouraging us to
decolonize the canon 'm academics are
doing it under pressure but what do you
think you've seen nothing your cutting
edge of decolonization on this well yes
I think a lot of that from what I know
has come from the students and there is
more and more appetite for knowing the
context in which these philosophers that
they study operate in and what other
things and ideas that can challenge it
that could be from other parts of the
world but they could also be perhaps
non-binary or brown women writing about
it so it's not just it's not just the
fact that it's the Western tradition
it's also the fact that knowledge is
produced in a certain manner and up till
very recently by a certain type of
person and students now start
identifying themselves as more than just
in this one category also one that shown
in their curriculum that's definitely
true of the of politics but also true of
history and increasingly of philosophy
and I yes so the pressure that I think
does come more from students but I'm
sure there's appetite at at all levels
including staff yeah yeah in my case I
have not been subject to any student
pressure of that kind it's just I've
been exposed to people talking about
really interesting ideas in these other
traditions and you know both the Indian
and the Islamic traditions for example
having Chinese philosophy is another
area and it's it's it's just become
obvious to me that these stereotypes are
false and I mean there's for example Lee
the stereotype of Indian philosophy has
mystical rather than rational just
obviously Rob once once you find out a
bit about him
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at III TV
you